my name is mathias von data and in
this video i explain to you what the
concert 1 intervals is and
we will start with that right away
that is it comes back into the interval
in statistics parameters of the
total population are often estimated on the basis of a random sample so
you have on the one  side the
population but since you cannot question the
whole population
you draw a sample and then you have
this sample with which you
want
to estimate a parameter from the population parameters that are estimated see e.g.
the mean value or the variance
an example you want the height of
all professionals  basketball players
in germany know is missing here you see
a sample
the mean value of the sample
most likely differs
from that of the
total population with each sample drawing
a different mean
value will probably result so the first sample
drawing we have a mean value in
the 2nd  per relationship will have a different
mean value and again in a
different sample relationship we
have a different mean value it can of
course also be said that
the foundation mean values ​​are exactly the
same purely by chance but that would be a big coincidence
now it is very useful to know an area
in  in which the true value will lie with a high
probability, so in the
end we now have the
mean values ​​of our sample
, but we actually want to know where the
mean value of the population is, of
course we are then interested in
which approximate range the waiting
mean value will be in
this range  could dance
interval called so that
confidence interval gives us a
range in which the true value
will lie with a certain probability
for the calculation of the
confidence interval must of course be
defined with what
probability a parameter should be in the
interval
as prob  It is hoped
that a 95 percent or
99 percent confidence level is
used. A 95
percent confidence interval is specified. You can be 95
percent confident that the true
parameter value is within that interval
. Let's look at the
confidence interval for the mean
at normal  distributed data are
your data normally distributed, the result is
that the confidence interval for the mean value for the
conference is equal to six
dashes plus - especially since it is the root of
hens is extreme the mean
value is currently value for the respective
confidence level
because is the sample size and it is
the standard
deviation - results from the fact that we
have the upper limit with plus
and the lower limit with -
how can you imagine this graphically
if we look at the curve of the
normal distribution
we can draw in the lower limit and the
upper limit
the  lower limit results in the middle of
st  rich - especially since it is the root of sir
where we take the minus for the lower
limit
and we have the upper limit with
extreme
an it through the root of hin
where the upper limit uses the plus
is
the range between the lower and the
upper limit  now the
confidence interval
a confidence level of 95 percent is
selected 95 percent of all values ​​are in
this range
but here you get mont in sap value
the time value for the respective
continent and you can read it from a
table in which iz values ​​for the
respective confidence level
are entered
For the confidence level of 95 percent
, for example, this results in a set value
of
1.96 This gives the equation that
the conference in the ball equals the line
plus minus 1.96 times the
standard deviation through group c
from the sample size is
the competency and  Of course, it is
possible to calculate for many statistical core
values, not just for the
middle  lwert it only says in which
area will be recognized eg 95 percent
i hope you liked the video
if you like drop by the data
tab or let's just look at the
next video which explains what the
confidence interval is for the perpetrator
and up to  next time